SAME TIME NOT TYING THE HANDS OF
POLICE.
BRET?
>> JOHN, THANK YOU.
THE SECOND HALF OF MY INTERVIEW
WITH ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR, WE BEGIN THIS EVENING FROM
THE COURTYARD OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE BY CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ORGANIZED
ELEMENTS OF SOME OF THE RIOTING
AND LOOTING.
HE SINGLED OUT ANTIFA YESTERDAY
BUT SAID AUTHORITIES ARE SEEING
A "WITCHES BREW" OF EXTREMIST
GROUPS.
>> EXTREME RIGHT GROUPS TRYING
TO LOOK LIKE EXTREME LEFT
GROUPS, EXTREME LEFT GROUPS
MASQUERADING AS EXTREME RIGHT
GROUPS, PLAYERS ON BOTH SIDES
TRYING TO SPIN UP VIOLENCE.
IT’S A COMPLICATED SITUATION.
>> YOU ASSUME THERE WILL BE MORE
REST AT THE ORGANIZING PART OF
IT SOON?
>> I THINK WE ARE VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON GETTING ON TOP OF
THESE GROUPS.
>> TURNING THE PAGE HERE TO THE
DURHAM REPORT AND WONDERING WHEN
THAT IS GOING TO COME OUT,
YOU’RE NOW A FEW MONTHS AWAY
FROM AN ELECTION AND SOME
EXPECTATION THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BE AT LEAST SOME BOMBSHELLS
IN THERE WITH THAT INVESTIGATION
INTO TRUMPED COLLUSION?
>> I CAN’T ADDRESS EXPECTATIONS,
I CAN SAY THAT EVEN WITH THE
DISRUPTION OF COVID AND THE FACT
THAT OUR COURT SYSTEM HAS
ESSENTIALLY BEEN SHUT DOWN, THE
TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
AGGRESSIVELY TO MOVE FORWARD AND
AS I’VE ALSO SAID THIS ISN’T
BEING DRIVEN BY PRODUCING THE
REPORT, WE ARE TRYING TO GET TO
A POINT WHERE WE CAN HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE ANYONE WHO CROSSED
THE LINE AND COMMITTED A
CRIMINAL VIOLATION.
THAT’S I THINK WHAT WILL BE THE
INITIAL STAGE OF A RESOLUTION OF
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
I ALSO THINK THERE WILL BE
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE ON SOME FORM.
>> FROM WHAT YOU’VE SEEN, CRIMES
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED.
>> BEFORE THE ELECTION I THINK
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE MODE
OF FORCE BEHIND THE VERY
AGGRESSIVE INVESTIGATION
LAUNCHED INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WITH A VERY SLENDER READ AS A
BASIS FOR IT, SPRING LOADED AT
THE OF JULY, INVESTIGATOR
CAMPAIGN AND IT REALLY WASN’T
MUCH THERE TO DO THAT ON AND
THAT BECAME MORE AND MORE
EVIDENT, THEY SEEM TO IGNORE ALL
THE EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
EVEN THOUGH WE WERE CLOSING DOWN
SOME OF IT, SAYING THERE’S
NOTHING HERE, FOR SOME REASON
THEY WENT RIGHT BACK AT IT EVEN
AT A TIME WHERE THE EVIDENTIARY
SUPPORT, CLAIM SUPPORT LIKE THE
DOSSIER WAS FALLING APART AND
IT’S VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH AND EVEN
MAKE PUBLIC IN TESTIMONY THAT
THEY HAD AN INVESTIGATION GOING
WHEN IT WAS BECOMING PAINFULLY
OBVIOUS OR SHOULD HAVE BEEN
OBVIOUS TO ANYONE THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING THERE.
>> YOU ALWAYS GET LUMPED IN WITH
BEING POLITICAL AND YOU PUSH
BACK AGAINST THAT, THE
CHARACTERIZATION THAT YOU ARE
THE PRESIDENT’S ATTORNEY BUT AS
YOU GET CLOSER TO AN ELECTION
DOESN’T RELEASING THIS REPORT
AND MAKING IT MORE AT RISK FOR
FALLING INTO THE POLITICAL
BUCKET?
>> I’VE PUBLICLY MADE CLEAR THAT
THIS IS NOT INVOLVED, LOOKING AT
PRESIDENT OBAMA OR
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, I THINK
THE PEOPLE WE ARE LOOKING AT ARE
NOT AT THAT LEVEL AND I THINK --
SOME OF THEM.
BUT HERE’S THE THING.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, POLICE ORGANIZATIONS OR
NATIONAL SECURITY ORGANIZATIONS
WERE USED FOR SPY ON A CAMPAIGN
AND THERE IS NO BASIS FOR IT AND
THE MEDIA LARGELY DROVE, ALL
KINDS OF SENSATIONAL CLAIMS WERE
BEING MADE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
THAT COULD HAVE AFFECTED THE
ELECTION AND LATER ON IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION THERE WERE
ACTIONS TAKEN THAT REALLY
APPEARED TO BE EFFORTS DESIGNED.
THAT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT AND IF
PEOPLE SAY THAT I’M POLITICAL
BECAUSE I’M LOOKING AT THOSE
POTENTIAL PIECES, SO BE IT BUT
THAT’S THE JOB OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> IF YOU HAD CHARACTERIZED THE
DURHAM REPORT AS YOU KNOW IT
NOW, IS IT GOING TO BE
EYE-OPENING FOR AMERICANS OR IS
THIS GOING TO BE A BLIP ON THE
ROAD?
>> I’M VERY TROUBLED BY WHAT IS
BEEN CALLED TO MY ATTENTION SO
FAR BUT I’M NOT GOING TO
CHARACTERIZE IT BEYOND THAT.
>> CAN YOU TELL US ANYTHING
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATIONS
UNMASKING?
>> UNMASKING IS NOT BY ITSELF
ILLEGAL BUT THE PATTERNS OF
UNMASKING CAN TELL US SOMETHING
ABOUT PEOPLE’S MOTIVATIONS IN
ANY GIVEN POINT OF TIME, TRYING
TO LOOK AT WATERFRONT IN MASKING
IN 2016.
>> IT’S NOT AGAINST THE LAW TO
UNMASK ANYONE BUT FOR EXAMPLE,
LET’S SAY FOR A PERIOD IN THE
SPRING THERE WAS A LOT OF HEAVY
UNMASKING DONE ON PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
THAT WOULD BE VERY RELEVANT AS
TO WHAT PEOPLE WERE THINKING AT
THAT TIME AND WHAT THEY’RE
MOTIVATIONS WERE.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE CASE,
YOU’RE IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO DISMISS THAT CHARGE AS THE
JUDGE CONTENDS ON AS NOW SHADOW
PROSECUTOR, MAKING A CHASE CASE
YOU CONTINUE.
>> THE ARGUMENT IS THE DECISIONS
WHETHER TO PURSUE AN INDIVIDUAL
TO THE PROSECUTION PROCESS, IT
IS BEST DONE IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AND NOT THE COURTS AND HE
IS ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO SET
HIMSELF UP IN AND AS AN
ALTERNATIVE PROSECUTOR.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE?
>> I’M NOT AWARE OF ANYTHING
LIKE THIS AND I THINK THAT’S WHY
THIS IS NOT BEING ARGUED AT THE
APPELLATE STAGE.
>> I KNOW YOU CAN’T GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS WITH THE DOJ AND
INSPECTOR GENERAL IDENTIFIED
THIS TOP FBI LAWYER THAT
FABRICATED EVIDENCE FOR WARRANTS
AGAINST CARTER PAGE TO SPY ON
HIM.
IT IS NOT PERSON STILL WORKING
AT THE FBI?
>> NO.
>> AND OTHER CHARGES?
>> I CAN’T DISCUSS FUTURE
CHARGES BUT I HAVE TO SAY I DO
FIND IT A LITTLE IRRITATING, THE
PROPENSITY IN THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC ON ALL SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM, SOMETHING TO
BE POLITICAL VIOLATION, THE OLD
SAYING, THE WHEELS OF JUSTICE
GRIND SLOW AND THEY DO GRIND
SLOW.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT CALL FOR THE
FACT THAT NO ACTION HAS BEEN
TAKEN YET THAT THAT MEANS THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET AWAY
WITH WRONGDOING.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS CRACKING
DOWN ON SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
FOR CENSORSHIP INCLUDING HIS OWN
TWEETS.
DOUBLE-CLICK ALLOW ALLOWS THESE
COMPANIES TO OPERATE AND IT’S
BEEN STRETCHED BEYOND ITS
ORIGINAL INTENT," DO YOU THINK
THESE FIRMS ARE CENSORING THE
PRESIDENT?
>> THESE ENTITIES ARE NOW
ENGAGED IN CENSORSHIP AND THEY
ORIGINALLY HELD THEMSELVES OUT
AS OPEN FORUM WHERE THIRD
PARTIES COULD COME AND EXPRESS
THEIR VIEWS AND THEY’VE BUILT UP
A TREMENDOUS NETWORK OF EYEBALLS
EYEBALLS, A LOT OF MARKET POWER
BASED ON THAT PRESENTATION AND
NOW THEY ARE ACTING MUCH MORE
LIKE PUBLISHERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
CENSORING PARTICULAR VIEWPOINTS,
PUTTING THEIR OWN CONTENT IN
THERE TO DIMINISH THE IMPACT OF
VARIOUS PEOPLES VIEWS.
>> IS THERE SOME ACTION YOU’RE
TAKING?
>> WE ARE LOOKING AS MANY OTHERS
ARE AT CHANGING SECTION 230
WHICH IS A RULE THAT PROVIDES
PROTECTION FOR THESE COMPANIES
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE CONGRESS,
YET.
>> PRISONER SWAPS WITH A WRONG
REQUIRED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO DROP CHARGES, IS THIS A GOOD
POLICY WHEN IRAN ARRESTS PEOPLE
FOR JUST BEING AMERICAN?
>> IT’S A POLICY THAT HAS TO BE
HANDLED WITH CARE, THAT WE DON’T
INVITE ANYMORE AMERICANS BUT THE
END OF A INDIVIDUAL CASES WE’VE
DONE THIS WE FELT THE BENEFITS
OUTWEIGH THE RISK.
>> SO IT WAS WORTH IT?
>> YES.
>> MARTA?
>> I CAN’T SAY.
>> WHAT IS IT LIKE WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THESE CRISES?
TWO IN A ROW NOW AND YOU BEEN
MEETING WITH HIM A LOT.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
INTERESTED IN HEARING ALL THE
VIEWS, THERE’S A LOT OF ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND HE MAKES A
DECISION AND I THINK HE’S BEEN A
GOOD LEADER.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT IS
REELECTED, WOULD YOU SERVE IN A
SECOND TERM?
>> I CANNOT ANSWER TO THAT.